there's a new hawaiian style restaurant  coming to the northwest part of town  island finn will open its doors this  weekend at the 215 in north decatur  right by lvac  the new restaurant brings some healthy  poke bowls to the area where you  have the choice to mix in your choice of  protein sauce rice with all the  different toppings  island fences face coverings and of  course social distancing will be  required  they were originally scheduled to open  back in february but of course then  things were closed due to covet  we've been planning to open for almost a  year now but obviously because of the  pandemic and everything going on it's  been a little bit hard but  we finally have that opportunity to open  so i'm really excited to open up this  weekend  it also has a location in boca park they  say with so much growth in the northwest  area  and the gym right by they thought that  was the perfect location